et bruxelles où un rassemblement en
soutien à julian assange est organisée
aujourd'hui le lanceur d'alert
emprisonné en grande-bretagne et menacé
d'extradition vers les etats-unis où il
encourt plus de 170 ans de prison pour
espionnage notamment le fondateur de
wikileaks avait révélé en 2010 des
documents mettant en cause l'armée
américaine on retrouve notre envoyé
spécial en belgique est elle charge
estelle
que faut-il retenir de cette journée
dédiée à la liberté d'expression et bien
une petite centaine de personnes se sont
rassemblées ici place de la monnaie à
bruxelles
rebaptisé la place 7 julian assange pour
l'occasion c'est ici qu'a été inauguré
une oeuvre de l'artiste italien est
david et dormino il s'agit de statue de
bronze représentant les lanceurs
d'alertés julian assange ou encore
edouard snowdon cette oeuvre elle sera
exposée ici à bruxelles pendant trois
jours avant de reprendre son tour du
monde elle rend hommage je cite au
courage des lanceurs d'alerté une
inauguration en présence de plusieurs
personnalités
un parmi elles le père de julian assange
il nous a donné des nouvelles de son
fils
je propose de l'écouter j'ai vu julian
hier il transmet ses salutations et son
amitié à l'académie pour cette
récompense aujourd'hui est heureuse mais
il n'est pas en bonne santé et le
rapport de nils mais les airs le
rapporteur spécial des nations unies sur
la torture et précis sur le sujet la
mobilisation et les manifestations
prennent de l'ampleur
tous les jours il y un nouvel événement
rien qu'aujourd'hui je me rends dans
cinq villes différentes pour assister à
des événements la mobilisation est
vraiment énorme
un petit peu plus tôt ce matin une
cérémonie était organisée au palais des
académies de bruxelles au cours de
laquelle des titres ont été des titres
honorifiques elles ont été remis à
julian assange mais aussi à edward tous
nos jeunes à chelsea à manille ou encore
à sarah harrison plusieurs personnalités
ont également pris à la parole comme le
fondateur de mediapart edwy plenel ou
encore le directeur de l'information de
la rtbf 1 assange day ans comme on le
nomme ici qui intervient un mois avant
l'ouverture à l'ombre du procès de
julian assange à son jeu qui je le
rappelle est ce que l'extradition vers
les états unis ainsi que 175 ans de
prison merci est el farj en direct de
bruxelles donc en belgique